THANK YOU.
MOMENTS AGO, RECEIVING WORD FROM
CAPITOL HILL AS YOU LOOK LIFE.
SENATOR CORKER WRAPPING UP THE
HEARING.
JUST GOT WORD SENATOR COONS,
SHAKING HIS HAND, GIVING HIM A
HUG BECAUSE SENATOR COONS
OFFERED IN THE SPIRIT OF
BIPARTISANSHIP, TO VOTE PRESENT.
CHANGES VOTE TO PRESENT WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE NOMINATION TO GO
FROM COMMITTEE TO THE SENATE
FLOOR.
WE WITNESS THE BIPARTISAN HUG AS
THEY FILE OUT.
ESSENTIALLY WHAT THIS MEANS IS
THE VOTE WAS TIED 10-10.
THEY WERE STUCK.
SENATOR COONS CHANGED HIS VOTE
TO PRESENT INSTEAD OF NO.
NOW THE CONFIRMATION GOES TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
THEY DO HAVE ENOUGH VOTES.
LET'S BRING IN OUR SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST BRIT HUME WITH
THIS BREAKING NEWS HAPPENING.
BRIT, YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS AND
THE WHOLE MOMENT THAT THIS WAS,
GETTING A SECRETARY OF STATE
NOMINATION OUT OF THE FOREIGN
POLICY COMMITTEE.
>> WELL, I THINK THEY HAD A
NUMBER OF OPTIONS.
THEY COULD AND RE-VOTED AFTER
JOHNNY ISAKSON GOT BACK FROM HIS
FUNERAL.
THEY COULD'VE HAD ANOTHER
MEETING AND VOTED AGAIN.
COULD HAVE BEEN REPORTED OUT OF
COMMITTEE WITH AN UNFAVORABLE
RECOMMENDATION WHICH GETS IT TO
THE FLOOR.
UNLESS DEMOCRATS WOULDN'T GO
ALONG WITH THAT WHICH WOULD SEEM
A LITTLE BIT ODD.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS ABOUT
AS GOOD AN OUTCOME AS YOU COULD
EXPECT FAR THE REPUBLICANS AND
THE NOMINEE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT'S CHARACTERISTIC OF THE
SENATE AT ITS BEST THAT A MEMBER
OF THE OTHER PARTY.
SENATOR COONS WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY VOTE NO ON THE FLOOR
BUT ALLOWING THE NOMINATION TO
PROCEED FOR THE FULL
CONSIDERATION BY THE SENATE IS
PRETTY MUCH IN THE TRADITION THE
WAY THE SENATE AS USUALLY
OPERATED.
IT'S A GOOD DEVELOPMENT.
>> Bret: YOU JUST SAW
SENATOR PAUL LEAVE THE COMMITTEE
ROOM.
OBVIOUSLY HAD A CHANGE OF HEART
AFTER MEETING WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND ALSO MEETING WITH CIA
DIRECTOR AND NOMINEE POMPEO.
>> WELL, I THINK IN THE CASE OF
RAND PAUL, HE'S IDIOSYNCRATIC.
HE IS ONE OF A KIND.
HE VOTES WHAT HE CONSIDERS TO BE
HIS CONSCIENCE.
IN THIS CASE HOWEVER, I THINK HE
MUST'VE HAD IT IN THE BACK OF
HIS MIND THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
POPULAR IN KENTUCKY AND THAT IF
HIS VOTE WERE THE DECISIVE VOTE
AND IT HAD THE EFFECT OF KILLING
THE NOMINATION WHICH I DON'T
THINK WOULD'VE HAPPENED.
IF IT HAD BEEN, IT WOULD'VE BEEN
PROBLEMATIC FOR HIM.
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND A MEETING
WITH NOMINATE POMPEO AND HE GETS
SOME BLAND ASSURANCES FROM
POMPEO THAT HE WILL SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICIES.
HOW COULD HE DO OTHERWISE.
AND THEN CHANGES HIS VOTE SO WE
CAN GO HOME AND SAY WELL, I
EXTRACTED THESE PROMISES AND NOW
I'M SATISFIED PRESUMABLY HIS
CONSTITUENTS WILL BE HAPPY.
>> Bret: WHAT DOES IT SAY
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE AND THAT YOU
HAVE THIS NOMINEE WHO IS THE CIA
DIRECTOR, JUST GOT BACK FROM
PYONGYANG EVENING WITH
KIM JONG UN, THE DELICATE DANCE
OF GETTING THIS MEETING
POTENTIALLY WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND THE NORTH KOREAN LEADER
STILL BEING WORKED OUT.
HAVING THIS ISSUE AND OBVIOUSLY
KIND OF A SPEED BUMP ALONG THE
WAY TO CONFIRMATION.
>> IT'S VERY MUCH A SIGN OF THE
TIMES.
WE LIVE IN AN AGE OF
PARTISANSHIP ON A LEVEL OF NEVER
SEEN BEFORE AND I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR ABOUT 40 SOME YEARS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING QUITE
LIKE THIS.
YOU HAD, DEMOCRATS KNOW
PERFECTLY WELL MIKE POMPEO ON
THE FACE OF IT IS PERFECTLY
QUALIFIED.
HE SERVED IN THE CONGRESS FOR A
LONG TIME.
HE HAS GLITTERING ACADEMIC
CREDENTIALS, CIA DIRECTOR.
NO REAL OBJECTIONS ABOUT HIM
THERE.
CLEARLY QUALIFIED.
AS YOU NOTE, HE'S BEEN ENGAGED
IN NEGOTIATIONS, VERY IMPORTANT
NEGOTIATIONS WITH NORTH KOREA
ALREADY.
THEN YOU HAD THINGS LIKE JEANNE
SHAHEEN, THE SENATOR FROM
NEW HAMPSHIRE SAYING SHE WAS
GONNA VOTE AGAINST HIM BECAUSE
OF HIS POSITION ON ABORTION.
IT'S ALMOST LAUGHABLE AT ANY
OTHER TIME BUT THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE.
PROFOUND PARTISANSHIP, AND THE
CONSTITUENCY FOR MANY DEMOCRATS
WHO WILL BE SATISFIED WITH
NOTHING LESS THAN ALL-OUT
OPPOSITION TO DONALD TRUMP AND
EVERY SINGLE THING HE DOES, EVEN
IF THESE THINGS ARE OTHERWISE,
WOULD NORMALLY GO FORWARD
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IT IS SET OF DONALD TRUMP THAT
HE'S STEPPED ALL OVER ALL KINDS
OF NORMS IN OUR COUNTRY.
PERHAPS HE HAS.
BUT HE HAS INDUCED HIS OPPONENTS
TO DO THE SAME
THIS BEHAVIOR TOWARD THIS
NOMINEE IS BUT ONE EXAMPLE.
>> Bret: THAT'S RIGHT.
AS WE LOOK AT THE STATE VISIT BY
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT AND HIS
WIFE, OBVIOUSLY THEY WILL BE
THIS STATE DINNER.
NO DEMOCRATS INVITED.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A FIRST AS
WELL.
>> YEAH, THAT'S ANOTHER NORM
THAT'S BEEN IGNORED.
I THINK THAT'S REGRETTABLE.
BUT I WOULD SAY THIS ABOUT THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH EMMANUEL
MACRON.
HE'S AN IMPORTANT ALLY FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
WE'VE HAD A LONG ALLIANCE WITH
THE FRENCH GOING BACK TO THE
REVOLUTIONARY WAR.
IT HAS STOOD FOR A LONG TIME,
BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN UNTROUBLED.
YOU MAY REMEMBER, BRET, WHAT
FITS THE FRENCH GAVE COLIN
POWELL AS HE WAS TRYING TO ROUND
UP SUPPORT IN THE U.N. FOR A
SECOND RESOLUTION TO AUTHORIZE
THE IRAQ WAR.
THE FRENCH FOREIGN MINISTER WAS
TRAILING HIM AROUND AND ARRIVING
EVERYWHERE HE HAD JUST LEFT TO
TRY TO TALK PEOPLE OUT OF GOING
ALONG WITH THE U.S.
THE RELATIONSHIP HAS HAD SOME
SERIOUS PROBLEMS IN RECENT YEARS
AND THE FACT THAT IT SEEMS SO
STRONG NOW DESPITE SOME OBVIOUS
DISAGREEMENTS.
PARIS CLIMATE TREATY BEING ONE
OF THEM.
AND OF COURSE THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL BEING THE OTHER.
IT'S STILL AN IMPORTANT
ACHIEVEMENT FOR THE PRESIDENT
THAT HE SEEMS TO HAVE COME TO
THIS RELATIONSHIP WITH ONE OF
OUR MOST IMPORTANT EUROPEAN
ALLIES AT A TIME WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CAN USE WHATEVER
SUPPORT IN EUROPE HE CAN GET.